so you both come from have quite the
pedigree and I wonder if some people
find self-driving cars scary self
driving trucks self-driving 18-wheelers
takes it to a whole new level what makes
you think this can be done on a massive
scale and safely thanks for having me a
causal scary truck so scary trucks are
also unsafe and the reason we felt
almost an obligation to live Google and
start a company is we had the knowledge
and understanding that the technology
can be applied to society sooner than
later and if you think about trucks
trucks are inherently unsafe we have
more than 4,000 fcl on public roads a
lot of issues across the hall forum
pollution to congestion with the right
technology the right approach the right
team and the right pace that were taking
we believe we can actually solve and
bring that society does your technology
eliminate the need for a driver entirely
or are there still things a human will
need the gun is not to eliminate the
need in the foreseeable future a the
first step that is going to take at
least few years is the drive wheel steel
in the cabin sort of elevating form a
driver to an or supervisor aim for the
truck and basically having the truck
drive itself for hundreds of miles while
the truck devil is basically supervising
is therefore fueling for inspection for
any safety issues that he'll need to
take control and life but initially the
driver is still there and at some point
do you see no driver at the eventual
future sure there's always a natural a
job cycle but I think that's going to
take a while and those need for those
trucks to be fueled to be a safely
driven and initially those drivers that
I can only drive those talks today nine
ten hours a day because it's a numbing
job it's very hard to concentrate out a
while we basically empower them to take
the truck and drive with 24 7 and
basically make more lively who would
finish the job early get back to the
family which doesn't c200 Daisy now our
we're contributing editor David
Kirkpatrick is still with us David jump
in here well I I love the idea and it
strikes me that public support for this
could grow much more rapidly than
support for self-driving cars because I
think most Americans think the trucks
are generally driven dangerously and we
know that drivers don't get enough sleep
they we always are being you know
surrounded by them on the highway and in
ways that feel unsafe so the idea that
they could be driven with a more
reliable manner in a computer augmented
approach is a great idea but I'm curious
tasley or do you think that this kind of
thing do you agree with that point and
do you think this could catch on more
rapidly than self-driving cars per se
that's our intent I don't only compare
necessarily trucks with the scars but
the intent is to move as fast as we can
we do believe this problem can be solved
but that's why we took that on highways
by definition is a much more
concentrated development there's no
pedestrians no crosswalks no traffic
lights and you can offer the sensors to
be in a much higher vantage point taking
a look much further down the highway you
can afford a much bigger budget to equip
the truck with a host of sensors that
will it allows to self drive so we
definitely see that problem as very
solvable just think about the energy we
all exit driving in a city street and
the mental energy we need to imply there
versus just driving on a highway for
hours of hours basically just trying to
keep the car or the truck between two
lanes